安楼有很多人都觉得我的皮膚很好
看起来不像油豆腐
我把我以前的照片放在提问去
你们可以看一下你们现在有没有我之前的眼中
那为什么出这条比机呢
因为之前我有杀了一个屏幕
是有豆腐寶导刷到我
但是不相信我的分享
因为他们比环果的皮膚看起来比较好吗
对于他们的现状没有太多餐烤性
那一般有豆腐的皮膚确实是会看起来
因为这会有银线的多豆腐眼
豆腐一年然后比较粗糙
感觉毛孔是比较粗大的
但我其实是12年的油豆腐
这条比机我就想跟大家分享
我是这款从一个油豆腐
变成现在这种比较光结的皮膚的
没有任何的广告
只是分享我的思路和解决方法
你们掌握了这颗油豆腐的
厚不思路
自己往里面全产品就可以了
先说豆豆腐一口的解决
我的解决方法就是先吃标
先把脸上油的
能看到当我的那些东西
先把它搞屏
如果你不怕做的话
就去震气
我以前的脸的那种超级眼中
就是这个颗是
你慢慢全部都是那个皮膚很刺
很多红种豆腐的白大罐
就会让我真清
他说真清可以把你的那个豆腐
已经你皮膚底下的那些脚杀
都给清出来
我第一次搞完这个吃
面目全飞感觉自己就跟毁容了一样
但是没过几天
真的一下子那个脸
我打就平滚了
豆豆必口在一夜之间
就好像被产品了一样
然后这个真清的习惯
我就是一直保持到现在
只要脸上爆发什么
豆豆必口就比较多的话
我就会去真清
之前我也排过一起
七天去豆豆必口的跟那视频
里面就露了
我去真清的视频
然后还有我的后续护服
我们担心就可以看一下
然后就是怎么不长豆豆必口
真清他只能治标
他只不了本
只要我们的皮膚出有的多
毛孤独注的
那清完没过多久就用会长
所以油豆体一定要并期的做毛孔的生存清潔
我自己的话
我是一周会做一次
每一次我就能清出超多的油脂
就是这些
我们在毛孔里的油脂材
让我们长这些必口豆豆
我的生存清潔的方法
我之前很想过
就是做这个
他让我的必口直接減少了
反正就是皮膚
就会觉得很光滑
而且毛孔干净了之后
他对于护服品的这个
吸收力就会大大的增加
所以我们长豆的后续
那个豆腐你的改善
就会特别的快
然后就是非常版的豆腐的问题
我有出过专门的
剧豆腐的这个香气的教程
非常简单
其实就是加速身体
在现在突然对豆腐的部分
我目前用来自由用的改善豆腐的产品
就是这个
然后还有一个面上
面丰我放弓都是我家里的没有
你们可以接图
没有广告
红豆腐就是用这个红开豆腐用这个
然后面丰是搭配它们两个一起用的
然后这两个也是可以叠图
叠出香味红好
然后我在最抗豆豆腐的过程中
做了一个很大的改变
就是开始在家用算
以前我是直感去做爽
它那边呢
是一个月只能说
一次
那我基本上我的这个长豆皮膚
就是还没有得到下一次去爽
我的那个皮膚
有肉与后春水羊冒出来
所以我就买了酸酸酸酸酸
我现在一周基本上会用个四五圈的酸酸的精华
或者酸酸酸酸酸酸酸酸酸酸酸
当于就是定时定期在给皮膚做烤光
树豆腐口口
带下两份脚致
让皮膚看下来更细腻光滑
就素业的时候脸就跟个反光板一样
然后非常的有光酸
肩尺用酸对于不长豆豆皮口
来说正事件非常非常重要的事情
我只要几天不用酸
皮膚摸下就会有那种科律感
然后那皮口又开始往来冒了
那很多简单都不会用酸
一用就翻车
然后腰膜就是用了没有用
所以我也有出整了
用酸的一个想象的脚致
真心做毛孔的生存心情
用酸酥脱毛孔
然后感上都用正级点做好了
一般脸上的比较大的
一数问题就感受得长得多了
我的脸上就只剩下
开老喝毛孔的问题了
我是了两种方法
都非常有效果
一个是用酸和A酸做循環护服
另一个就是用高龙度的
先先按去搭配A酸
这两种的推老鼻子
細毛孔的效果都出气得好
真的就是用了一段时间
就会感觉毛孔是
肉羊可见的比起你皮膚换人一起
我自己是用了五年的A酸
然后我从来都没有做过什么
超少啊
认
其实没有推老酱
但是我现在三十次
我还是觉得我皮膚非常的紧智
而且我连法令稳都没什么
所以它是真的很牛
而是它不只可以一边帮我们
就进行可以了
还能一边帮我们
就动动而且不只是
我用了之后有效果
我分享给我身边很多朋友
他们用完之后
也是跨到停不下来
这个护服它是一步一步以过来的
先把豆豆烹好
然后再把人都应高好
然后你再去提升这个分析
你到这一步的时候
护制真是会有很明显的提神
脸看起来是这种
气平的肉的
毛孔也是不怎么明显
好多希望我这十二年的一个护服经验
护服俗能够帮助到你们
你们还有什么问题的话
可以在平去跟我留言